there's a New Yorker article that Hassan
minhaj may have been fabricate
fabricating some things in uh his
Netflix specials you know the prom story
right what's the prom story like we were
cool a long time ago I'm talking like
2012. I didn't know this was a lie I
thought all the reasons I don't [__]
with this guy this wasn't one of them
we're sitting at a [__] Diner and he
tells me this story as a trauma story
I'm dead you probably said something
like you went to their houses he's like
yeah and he was like all right keep that
part that was good Sonny said I got to
the door this is any joke to get me on
his side obviously he's like so I can't
trust white women and I was like yeah
dog that makes sense but I will be on I
remember when he said her parents said
to him it's just not a good fit and then
I remember being like that okay well
your parents would say the exact same
thing it's just not a good fit your
parents would say that more your parents
would be like [__] you thinking man this
is not a good fit she's not the same
country not the same race not the same
Faith what's going on that's not a good
fit mad in Congress